Gwyneth Paltrow is a lady of many
talents in addition to acting singing
writing books and raising children she's
also now a marvel secret spoiler in an
interview with Titan Publishing's
official Avengers infinity war magazine
Paltrow who portrays Pepper Potts in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe may have
spilled a major spoiler about Avengers 4
the actress opened up about her
character's relationship with Robert
Downey jr. 'he's Tony Stark better known
to the world as Iron Man and as it turns
out her scene in infinity war might have
been a prelude for big news to come from
stark tower in the beginning of infinity
war Tony tells Pepper that he had a
dream she was pregnant
pepper brushes the comment aside neither
confirming nor denying whether she's
actually expecting before Tony jets off
to the cosmos to do battle with danos
while Pepper might have been playing coy
Paltrow didn't hold back she seems to
tell fans in the magazine feature that
Pepper has not only survived
Thanos as Infinity Gauntlet snap but
that she's also with child saying Pepper
and Tony have had a really long journey
together
she obviously starts as his dutiful
assistant and then the relationship
evolves and now this decade later
they're married and they have a child
their relationship has evolved in all of
the ways that great romances evolved the
turn of phrase Paltrow used here still
invites some questions of course by
saying the two have a child it could
mean that she's pregnant in Avengers 4
which would mean that the film picks up
just after infinity war or it could mean
that by the time the next film comes
along she'll have already had a little
one with the billionaire philanthropist
superhero
of course the lovebirds could always end
up adopting a child since there's bound
to be plenty of orphans left in the wake
of Thanos
snap but in either case it looks like
the Starks will become a party of three
in Avengers 4 somehow considering how
protective Marvel is over their plot
details it's pretty baffling how
Paltrow's remarks here made it to Prince
but perhaps the studio just wanted to
give fans a reason to be optimistic
after so much devastation and infinity
war yeah
after all what better way to say goodbye
to the guy who started it all than to
make him turn a complete 180 from the
selfish spoiled magnet
once was into a doting dad who wants to
live a humble quiet life instead
whatever does come of this news let's
just hope we get some kind of happy end
and not the Tony and his son die
together one as seen in the comics we'll
know for sure what Paltrow's mention of
pepper secret bun in the oven entails
when Avengers four arrives on May 3rd
2019 thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to